hello and welcome to this video playing
oh my goodness Varis katha Bowdre Huma
Wow okay let's get rolling with the
Russell Nemo yeah we've seen quite a bit
of the Russell Nemo in the World
Championship match
I think Fabiano tried it three times and
once he tried this which I have in my
book might keep it simple easy for book
and he mangas play d5 that was somewhat
expected after his plane the first two
black games and yeah he come on up late
um before that's an interesting move I
have it in the book as a as a
recommendation if you want to surprise
your opponent and but Magnus was very
well prepared and equalized before it's
interesting with that that is what I
have in my book it's um I mean that is a
it's called keep it simple and before
it's not keeping it simple to rather
make it complicated yeah this is um very
much comparable to Game three in the
match I think the main is also played
with Queen c7 I'm also going with before
as Quran I did this is also my
recommendation against Queenie 7 oh it's
this a3 before is a way to try to get to
the slide pawn weaknesses that black has
it's not much in terms of weaknesses
it's not that black isn't trouble or
anything but it's it's it's the thing to
try him
I came probably Bishop III put a little
bit more pressure on c5 like will
probably take at some point I still keep
forgetting that I can paint during the
game probably he will take them often
you you can simply over protect the pawn
but
evade us not on him that is too slow
yeah so he decides to capture and now I
have a little bit of pressure against a
seven it's however upon that it's
difficult to capture
so always traps piece traps possible
okay I should have thought about this
for a moment maybe you know ff5 wasn't
move that anyway it didn't happen so
what it's Knight b6
let's move I don't understand really if
you play the night somewhere where I'm I
mean there's absolutely nothing to
attack it's often a bit questionable
really the night it's just looking at
protected squares it's much more natural
to play rook e8 9 f8 to e6 that's a good
spot for the night okay what I'm trying
it with rook a5 is to play Quinta in one
get more pressure against the a pawn and
against the e5 pawn oh that's a
concession that's a bit of a concession
hmm still how to do that now for white
okay now Queen a one looks a tad stupid
when when a7 is not attacked anymore I
would still like to get some pressure
going here against f5
it's however difficult to ever take the
pawn right it's really difficult
okay you see playing yeah at least I'm
preventing f5 that way as there's too
much pressure on e5
I can I can also maybe think about Queen
to c3 at some point which would maybe
[Music]
Queen C 3 is actually threatening b5
that's interesting
probably still a bit of a naive movie F
he will have some way to prevent b5 yeah
but it's a it's not so super obvious
that I'm threatening it so I can't some
push this back or he gives me the bishop
is also possible I mean that's the wrong
way to phrase it
he allows me let's say - yes - to get
get his bishop and I have not I don't
have to play against the bishop a
anymore
now b5 that was the idea yeah should
Brooke don't see why not
you cannot take with either pawn and I'm
threatening to take a 6 and destroy his
pawn structure
one key element of whites game is always
that this Bishop one g7 is not a really
stellar piece on g7 oh it's not good
so I'm winning a pawn hooray what did
yes is heroine once a and half half of
its life as a chess players counting
pawns it's not completely wrong in case
I'm trying to double on b7 here on the
seventh rank and it's a very nice
position I'm a pawn up and I have the
more comfortable and the more
comfortable piece placement comfortable
as a very yeah I kind of understand that
it's just terrible to play every single
piece that I have is better than his
piece he cannot move I suspect that the
engine gives a really huge evaluation
you already I'm almost +3 it's not a
surprise okay so that's him a bit of a
bit of a brief analysis here he went 5
and this is the the position where I'm a
Khurana played dude this b4 move it's
interesting I don't quite remember how
it went yeah like this it was something
like this right yeah I realized that
before I am when I was writing my book
but I couldn't really find something
super convincing for white and it turned
out that there wasn't anything it's a
good surprise weapon though if you want
something funky probably now it's not a
great surprise anymore if it was played
in a World Championship match but like
objectively it's not a bad line ok so I
took on c6 as I had analyzed my book d3
Queen c7 and now yeah you have more than
one idea III before is one of them the
engine also gives stuff like a four 93
93 is a bit odd you can do that b5 is
not a good move for black so you get to
c4
yeah but this is a3 before is
interesting it's a very
forward way to play trying to yeah get
to queenside weaknesses it may it might
look a counterintuitive to do that
because I mean I'm getting rid of his
double pawn but the double pawn is not a
problem here for black anyway it's not
rican anyway so it felt very normal and
now he took on before which is a sad
concession as mentioned some takes
castles ninety to ninety six I felt must
be wrong that is just a bad square for
the night
so I was surprised to see this move and
interesting at the engine c4 or Queen d1
no love for okay five I don't think it's
a bad move quit b1 is however also quite
quite sensible maybe going for b5 again
yeah I think this okay the engine gives
us about the same evaluation as the
other moves a six Queen a1 yeah and okay
yeah now the screen c3 is heading this
setting up b5 I'm surprised that the
engine gives c4 in this position really
intending b5 and I just said it's not
[Music]
not too bad I mean it looks a little bit
odd because this is some really not a
good pawn but he probably never gets
them he never gets to the pawn I just
get mean b5 and I'm better next I mean
for example I mean this was c5 even this
is this is the second idea and this is
of course a fantastic position for white
Wow
yeah yeah this is this is absolutely
absolutely great because he he cannot
move a pawn here ever anymore I'm having
excellent control worldís is weak
position so that's the secondary idea c4
was very strong move then hmm
interesting
okay well I went Queen c3 intending b5
and gather way it turned out that that
was possible and 97 is a mistake then he
has to go poop da door something
probably them something like this and
now b5 it's not as effective
maybe I'm so playing at yeah this I
Scott 94 McQueen 8 5 ok yeah ok yeah B 5
then this even here's a style advantage
but you can dis certainly up for debate
you can play h3 or something and just be
a bit better
yeah iam this is just great for what I'm
threatening ba 6 to destroy the pawn
structure and just nothing to do the way
it turned out I'm just a pawn up and
then yeah yeah this is just terrible for
Becca yeah ok guys thanks for watching